BUT THE PEOPLE WILL BE HAPPY.
THE PEOPLE OF THE WORLD WILL BE
HAPPY.
NEXT WE WILL TURN TO
UNPRECEDENTED PROSPERITY THROUGH
OUR PRO-AMERICAN POLICIES.
WE’LL PASS NEW TAX CUTS TO BOOST
TAKE-HOME PAY PERIOD WILL BE
CUTTING TAXES VERY SUBSTANTIALLY
SUBSTANTIALLY.
WE’VE HAD TREMENDOUS GROWTH
UNTIL HE GOT HIT WITH THE CHINA
VIRUS.
WE WILL CONTINUE OUR HISTORIC
REGULATORY CAMPAIGN.
AS YOU KNOW, IN THREE AND A HALF
YEARS WE HAVE CUT MORE
REGULATIONS THAN ANY OTHER
ADMINISTRATION, NO MATTER HOW
LONG OR WHAT PERIOD OF TIME YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT.
WE WILL ENACT FAIR TRADE DEALS
AND WE ARE WORKING ON SEVEN
MAJOR FAIR TRADE DEALS RIGHT
NOW.
WHEN I SAY "FAIR," FOR HER OUR
COUNTRY.
OUR COUNTRY IS RIPPED OFF BY
EVERY NATION.
FRIEND, FOE, DIDN’T MATTER.
EVERY NATION WAS RIPPING US OFF
AT A LEVEL THAT IS JUST
UNBELIEVABLE, TO BE HONEST.
WE ARE GOING TO BE EXPANDING
OPPORTUNITY ZONES, AND WE WILL
KEEP THAT GOING.
IT’S BEEN A TREMENDOUS PROGRAM.
I WANT TO THANK SENATOR SCOTT,
SOUTH CAROLINA, FOR COMING UP
WITH THAT WHOLE CONCEPT.
I LIKED IT RIGHT AWAY.
THIS HAS TURNED OUT TO BE A
TREMENDOUS THING, ESPECIALLY FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS AND
HISPANIC-AMERICANS.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO UNLEASH
AMERICAN ENERGY.
WE ARE NUMBER ONE OF THE WORLD,
AND WE ARE TOTALLY ENERGY